et la vie sobre est-ce que vous avez vu
la technique de marty cas pour se faire
embrasser en fait elles baissent la tête
de plus en plus avec un peu saoul
elle est de plus en plus en balladur en
fait intéressé ça je vous demande de
vous arrêter à yako laisse deux fronts
collège de france commencera à produire
des six a alors est ce que vous n'avez
des techniques vous pour embrasser les
filles jean michel lemaire c'est quoi
votre technique pour est ce qu il ya
toujours le moment mine de rien c'est le
moment où on se dit on va tenter le truc
le moment si cette seconde 1 vous la
connaissez cette seconde on se dit est
ce que ça va passer
ou est-ce que ça va casser et nous
généralement dans l'équipe on se dit ça
va casser mais on y va quand même parce
que nous sommes des kamikazes donc
forcément il ya cette fraction de
seconde
salé où vous êtes dit non et puis là
finaux fait non c'est pas du tout ce que
tu crois mais vous quel est votre
technique alors ma du coup je veux pas
prendre ce risque
by d'amande donc du coup je m'approche
pas doucement parce que là évidemment je
vous laisse trop le temps de dire
nombreuses fenêtres à vous j'ai mal à la
sauvage la techno du cobra et tout d'un
coup de coude libre un peu bush a que
comme ça et ça lui en fait si vous
voulez après super chaud un coût non non
non mais à ce qu est ce que vous pouvez
faire sans embrasser jusqu'au bout
valérie bénaïm d'accord vous la ramenez
chez elle valérie mois juste avant alors
valérie vous la ramenez chez elle vous
êtes un match est elle d'accord alors
que tu lui dis bon ben ali cela coûte
cher
j'ai passé une très bonne soirée
j'aimerais bien te voir demain et puis
est ce que je t'ai dit que
samara
cela fait du mal comme ça
ça c'est bon comme ça
attendez valérie attendez attendez joue
je vous rassure calme aschieri ah ouais
mais je peux bien pourquoi il prend
beaucoup de place à la télé du cobra été
réalisé par un professionnel de la
trachée vous c'est très dangereux
je vais pouvoir
j'aimerais ce qu'on peut en voir la
suite masquer sa samad mais j'aime bien
est ce que c'est ce qui en a d'autres
tous les techniques jean-luc aumans vous
avez une technique assez peu confiance
en ma séduction donc je propose un
service ça comme ça je vous le dis oui
je propose un service c'est quoi je leur
ai dit est ce que tu voudrais que je te
des tarterêts les dents